comme on dit jamais deux sans trois et
vous étiez quand même certains
l'attendre allez on repart sur une
petite pluie de théories sur les dlc de
smash bros ultimate toujours en
compagnie des fameux you et nm lt du
studio pokémon
bref vous connaissez le concept et puis
il n'y a pas de pluie sans théorie que
j'écris ça
[Musique]
harley c'est la protagoniste principal
des premiers jeux de la licence puyo
puyo le tetris like de sega dispose en
effet de tout un tas de petits
personnages tout mignon dont celui qui
nous intéresse ici mènent mlc un tetris
comment tu veux en faire un personnage
en fait c'est là que ça devient
intéressant ragots je vois deux choses
essentielles à implémenter dans le
gameplay d'arles et la magie et les
pouilles aux harley c'est une magicienne
qui utilise tout un panel de sort quand
elle fait des combos dans puyo puyo pour
la petite histoire avant priaulx pouliot
a arrêté dans un rpg mado monogatari
avec des sorts des monstres dont l'époux
you on peut puiser dans ce jeu est il
bien entendu dans la licence proprio
pour y trouver ses soeurs fétiche pour
les puyo je vois plein moyen de les
intégrer aux attaques d'arles et on peut
l'imaginer invoqués et faire tomber
dépouillant l'attaquant comme ce que
fait bâiller et avec ses jambes et ses
bras tu démons ou alors frappé à coups
de tuyaux comme pacman avec les fantômes
ou bien pourquoi pas faire comme les
pikmin d'olimar mais pour harley et
pourraient poser des plutôt gris pour
entraver l'adversaire féline de quatre
plus hauts que disparaisse occasionnant
des dégâts et en étant fou on peut même
imaginer qu'en utilisant un certain type
de pouliot sur certains ennemis ça
augmenterait dégâts ya peut-être même
des trucs à faire avec le sceptre de l'y
obligeait déjà implémenté dans ce match
et qui vient d'une autre licence de
puzzle-game panel des pognes tu vas trop
loin je pense achever oui bah ouais j'ai
peut-être trop long mais tout ça pour
vous dire qu imaginer des attaques pour
ce personnage c'est pas le problème
le véritable problème c'est la licence
en elle-même car ouais c'est sa licence
a eu un succès monumental dans les
années 90 c'est plus trop le cas
aujourd'hui
il ya encore des jeux qui sortent de
temps en temps sur switch notamment mais
c'est pas fou je mise le choix ce
personnage surtout sur son succès passé
je me dis que si on veut avoir un
personnage dans l'esprit de terry qui
marquent une époque un cycle jeu
d'arcade c'est un personnage idéal et
son arrivée dans ce match apporterait
vraiment du frais dans le dlc game ce
serait le premier personnage
exclusivement féminin du lot elle
représenterait un style de jeu encore
absent dans ce match les puzzle game et
les tetris like son esthétique dessinée
et phoebe trancherait complètement avec
tous les autres persos a lancé dans les
dlc et les pouilles auront de quoi
apporter des mécaniques unique
de plus c'est une licence de sega est
bon on a vu avec joker personnage d'une
de leur société et qu'ils étaient prêts
à donner des combattants pour ces dlc
c'est pas un personnage de mai gagnant
comme ça mais
n'a que du positif à apporter à ultimate
i'm a [ __ ]
voici un petit graphique qui a été
constituée sur la base des réponses
après la révélation de personnages dlc
sur les compte officiel twitter de
nintendo les résultats ont été triés
selon trois régions japon etats unis et
europe et même si l'on peut remettre en
question la fiabilité du protocole de
sondages je crois tout de même que l'on
peut dire que le personnage de sora
suscite un engouement certain
à travers le monde après nous savons
qu'un sondage random n'est pas suffisant
pour légitimer un nouveau challenger
oui c'est pourquoi allons plus loin
peut-être que certaines et certains ne
connaissent pas sera le héros de la
série kingdom hearts ou alors juste de
loin le fameux gars qui se bat avec une
grosse clé dans les univers disney avec
mickey tout son groupe
et pourtant il s'agit là d'un personnage
véritablement important puisque la saga
kingdom hearts est le fruit de
l'association entre on va faire simple
pour la vidéo disney et square enix
c'est un crossover fou le projet de
plusieurs années la licence est un
véritable succès commercial
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas prêt de
s'arrêter là la série comporte déjà
environ une douzaine d'épisodes sortie
sur différentes consoles dont notamment
je vous donne en mille des jeux
exclusifs à des supports nintendo
un épisode sur game boy advance 2
épisode sur ds et enfin un dernier sur
3ds en 2012
tout de suite on le voit la nintendo n'a
jamais fermé ses portes à la série et
inversement les jeux kingdom hearts sont
ce qu'on appelle d action rpg et à
partir de là je pense que vous avez déjà
compris cearà est un combattant et de ce
fait il n'est pas difficile de lui
imaginer tout un éventail d'attac
maîtrise du combat au corps à corps
capacités magiques une très belle
agilité fluidité aérienne saura n'a pas
été taillé pour les combats de smash
bros mais presque en termes de
spécificité de mécanique propre à la
licence que l'on pourrait intégrer dans
ce match on peut envisager comme dans
certains kingdom hearts une
transformation de la qibla d'un certain
niveau de pourcentage infligée pour
augmenter temporairement une ou
plusieurs statistiques ou bien comme le
propose intelligemment super smash flash
2 le système de commande de kingdom
hearts birth by sleep pourrait aussi
être inclus pour créer un roulement sur
différents sorts avec une seule
combinaison de touches pour expliquer
plus simplement le b bat pourrait donner
à tour de rôle un sort brasier un sort
glaciers puis 1 / foudre vous l'aurez
donc compris cearà serait très chouette
dans ce match ok mais moi j'ai un soucis
avec sera en fête disney c'est pas
vraiment une entreprise ouverte avec ses
listes
ans donc pourquoi ils le maîtrisent un
smash et bien j'aurais tendance à faire
l'hypothèse suivante alors que des
studios de jeux vidéo ont dû abattre
leurs plus grosses cartes pour intégrer
smash bros il suffit seulement à disney
d'arrivée avec sora pour partir à la
conquête d'un territoire et qu'on se le
dise
j'adore saura je suis un grand fan de
kingdom hearts à l'échelle du jeu vidéo
c'est un personnage important mais il
faut bien reconnaître qu'à l'échelle de
disney dans sa globalité
ce n'est qu'une petite partie le fait
qu'un représentant annexes se retrouve
dans smash bros et non le grand mickey
est quelque chose d'extrêmement fort
symboliquement disney place ses pions
sans avoir à bouger son droit
[Musique]
m
l'idole de mon enfance et mon tout
premier jeu vidéo merde quoi je suis
obligé de parler de crash alors oui
j'affirmais que je ne voyais pas crash
dans smash à la base mais la mentalité
et les objectifs de sakurai ont changé
lors du premier set de combattants prévu
pour les dlc les ambitions de sa corail
n'étaient pas les mêmes que celles
d'aujourd'hui
tout comme celle des autres éditeurs
smash bros est le jeu de combat cumulant
le plus de ventes
et c'est aujourd'hui un symbole la
bibliothèque rassemblant le plus de
combattants différents donc aujourd'hui
je l'admets j'avoue que je vois bien
crash dans ce match ce dernier est une
icône de la playstation est surtout le
symbole de naughty dog
bien qu'il ait été racheté par
activision après plus de 20 ans crash a
subi un regain de popularité et
d'intérêt grâce à ces remakes et c'est
un argument énorme pour une potentielle
venu dans ce match
néanmoins crash n'a jamais révolutionner
les jeux de plateforme
alors en quoi se différenciera t-il des
autres comme rayman ou spa héros et bien
crash est l'un des rares jeux étranger à
s'être popularisé au japon et c'est un
argument de poids quand on sait que
smash bros et japonais et que la plupart
des combattants populaire dans ce match
l'étaient déjà dans ce pays voire même
originaire également il faut penser
gameplay chaque personnage issu d'un dlc
dans smash bros apporte avec lui une
identité propre quant à son gameplay et
c'est là que crache peut se démarquer
prenons par exemple la tornade qui est
son coût signature ce dernier pourrait
apporter le fait de renvoyer n'importe
quel projectile grâce à une tornade bien
placé tout comme nes et lucas avec leur
battes de baseball par exemple où la
branche de bois il pourrait lancer dès
wemba et non des pommes un bien sûr posé
des caisses surprise des tmt des nitro
genre imaginez s'ils crachent gagner une
protection en cassant une caisse avec à
coup à coups de dents ou se régénérer
des pourcentages avec des booms pas il
pourrait également utiliser son jetpack
comme recovery utilisé pour l'avenir
comme saïbi amener les pouvoirs qu'il
obtient au cours de son
aventure dans le troisième opus comme le
bazooka par exemple ou bien même son
plaquage avec un fine au smash avec akuo
à coup son masque qui le rend invincible
bref une multitude de possibilités
existent ce n'est qu'une question de
droit et de motivation de sakurai
[Musique]
lui le dernier personnage dlc qui inclut
le rang des combattants à savoir baylacq
de fire emblem c'est quasi sûr qu'on
aura un personnage nintendo dans cette
nouvelle vague de dlc et la licence qui
s'imposent le plus c'est bien pokémon le
dernier jeu est sorti ya pas longtemps
il ya eu des dlc qui ont été annoncées
et ses pokémon quoi donc sans tourner
autour du pot moi je vois bien chief
ours comme pokémon sélectionnés pourquoi
pas d'un des trois starters de galard
les trois starters de base ont aussi
leur chance mais j'ai une petite
préférence pour chez four ce déjà ce
pokémon est aussi un starter c'est avec
lui qu'on fera la voiture du premier dlc
de pokémon épées et boucliers
donc de ce point de vue là il est aussi
légitime que cette fois qu'on greffe
ensuite c'est un pokémon qui est taillé
pour ce match imaginez il pourrait se
battre en alternant entre ces deux
styles point final pour une forme
bourriner lente et 1000 points pour une
forme beaucoup plus rapide d'après ce
qu'on a compris le pokémon ne peut
apprendre que l'un de ces deux styles
mais pour ce match ça peut s'adapter
pour qu'ils passent de l'un à l'autre
avec un petit peu bas par exemple ce
pokémon dispose vraiment de tout plein
de spécificités qui peuvent s'ajouter
dans son gameplay entre sa maîtrise du
kung fu ces deux styles son attaque
signature qui varient en fonction de son
style ses deux formes giga max ya un
beauf 7° winner qui demandent qu'à être
préparés pour ces deux gigas max ça
pourrait donner un final smash par style
comme pour le personnage de ken qui
dispose d'un final ce match différent en
fonction de sa proximité avec son
adversaire l'avantagent que chief ours à
par rapport aux autres secteurs de gare
ce qui fait partie du dlc de joie son
inclusion dans smash bros serait un
énorme coup de pouce pour le tout
premier dlc de la série pokémon
ce serait complètement dans la logique
économique de nintendo comme peut en
témoigner il annonce du décès de fire
emblem kroziz juste après le smash
direct mais les trois starters du jeu de
base tu en penses quoi
concrètement je trouve que l'e3 pourrait
s'adapter de ouf les argus serait le
sniper avec des attaques à distance et
un corps à corps à coups de coups des
coups de genoux comme on peut le voir
dans le jeu ce qui me pose problème avec
lui c'est sa ressemblance physique avec
amphi nos vies mais sans ça il est tout
bon tir au but ce serait un personnage
rapide et puissant et qui se ferait et
j'étais très vite avec des coûts de
jambes qui pourrait renvoyer les
projectiles
rappelant sa capacité signature change
côté et un bal a enflammé dans lequel il
joue très pour le propulser sur l'ennemi
après on a eu dracaufeu effet inferno
comme forme finale de starter
donc on met un troisième de type feu ça
fait beaucoup la négo rythmique c'est
celui que je préférais pour le côté feu
plantes au du tri
avec en finale bis effet l'inferno mais
j'imagine trois personnages comme donkey
kong faudrait un gameplay autour des 11
du tambour et des baguettes pour
diversifier les quatre starter ont donc
bel et bien leur chance mais j'ai plus
envie de croire en chie force pour plus
de kung fu dans ce match
[Musique]
à
vous connaissez les jeux vidéo tales of
j'en suis pas si sûr bon je vais pas
vous faire le détail puisque sakurai
s'en chargera lui-même lorsqu'il fera
l'historique de la série mais on va
faire un petit point quand même
tales of est une licence véritablement
importante c'est une quinzaine de jeux
principaux le premier temps sorti en
1995 et un nombre à peu près équivalent
de spin off
la série est également connue et encensé
pour le charme de son esthétique manga
aussi tales of ce n'est pas juste une
anecdote dans le jeu vidéo japonais vous
dire un nouvel épisode doit encore
sortir en 2020 et parmi tous ces jeux il
y a eu tel of symfonia qui a marqué
l'arrivée de la série sur continent
européen
s'ouvrant ainsi au marché global du jeu
vidéo donc japon etats unis et l'europe
ce jeu est un épisode important
charnière est synonyme pour beaucoup de
premiers contacts avec la série est
justement lloyd est l'un des personnages
principaux si ce n'est même le
personnage principal de tales of
symphonia
du coup log seulement de par l'histoire
de la série est déjà un symbole le
représentant de l'ouverture au monde
pour la licence est très probablement le
personnage le plus représentatif de
tales of
il apparaît régulièrement dans d'autres
épisodes de la série et à l'époque il a
même été invité à rejoindre le casting
de soulcalibur legends sur wii on peut
vraiment dire que c'est un argument sa
faveur ce dans le fond oui après j'ai
pas dit que c'était un super jeu hein et
puis bon si on s'arrête encore un coup
sûr le sondage que vous est présenté
tout à l'heure le public japonais semble
plutôt d'accord avec cette idée
d'ailleurs pour la petite anecdote des
rumeurs avaient même circulé quant à son
intégration dans le casting de super
smash bros brawl
autant ça pouvait paraître probable mais
sans plus pour brawl autant à partir de
ce match 4 on était déjà en mesure de se
poser des questions et oui puisque à ce
moment là et c'est toujours le cas
aujourd'hui deux entreprises sont
principalement au développement de super
smash bros d'un côté sora ltd la société
fondée en 2005 par sa couronne après son
départ de hal laboratory et de l'autre
côté bandai-namco et qui édite et
développe directement ou indirectement
les jeu tales of et je sais je sais
c'est bandai-namco exactement et avec ça
je pense que je n'ai pas besoin de vous
faire de dessin lloyd est un épéiste à
deux sabres privilégiant la réactivité
et la vitesse
entre les attaques qui réalise des
petits enchaînements aérien celles qui
peuvent provoquer des renversements
d'autres qui font appel aux magies
élémentaires
il ya vraiment beaucoup de possibilités
dans les jeux de la série certaines
attaques sont au fur et à mesure du jeu
combinées entre elles pour obtenir des
techniques plus puissante et ouvrant de
nouveaux combos ainsi dans smash bros on
pourrait imaginer que les compétences de
lloyd s'améliore à mesure que ces
pourcentage augmente par exemple cros
démoniaque pourrait se transformer en
double creux démoniaque puis en cao
démoniaque et tempêtes se changerait en
tempête
oméga ou tempêtes bestial ce sont
quelques idées mais ce qui serait
intéressant avec ce concept c'est que
des combos différents puissent déployer
à mesure que les techniques de log
évoluent sur une même vie et du coup
pourquoi est-ce qu'on aurait le droit à
l'oeil dans ce match ultimate alors
qu'il ya déjà un costume de ce
personnage pour les mii et bien figure
toi que le costume en question n'existe
que dans ce match 4 aucune trace de sa
présence dans l'intimé simple
coïncidence
nous le verrons bien
[Musique]
bon dans tes tout le monde l'attendait
comme dernier dlc face à saurat et c'est
donc bye laisse au plus grand désarroi
de certains qui a finalement intégré
l'opus ultimate néanmoins il faut je
pense le garder de côté dans tes est un
personnage iconique du jeu vidéo à
l'heure actuelle grâce à sa licence
devil may cry son gameplay pour ce match
serait tout facile à imaginer
d'ailleurs ce dernier est un pur
combattant pour ce match
au vu de ses capacités entre points
sabre flingue et même moto il y a de
quoi faire mais il faut penser en termes
d'apport dans le gameplay et
d'innovation déjà à la manière de joker
dans tes pourrait se battre de façon
classique avec son sabre et des flingues
pour les attaques ce match l'utilisation
bien bourrine de larmes cavaliere est
pour moi une évidence
dante est d'ailleurs plutôt aérien dans
sa saga et peut se téléporter sur une
courte distance cela pourrait lui servir
de harry cover ou de saïbi et enfin
comme particularité son chapeau dr faust
c'est une idée à ne pas négliger
dans tous les cas on sait que capcom et
nintendo s'entendent très bien surtout
du côté de sakurai capcom sont les
éditeurs de mega man et des street
fighter et la firme possède déjà trois
personnages de leur jeu chez ultimate
sakura il lui est fan de la saga street
fighter autant que moi je suis fan de
final fantasy
il se peut donc qu'une nouvelle alliance
soit renouvelée néanmoins cela peut être
également une faiblesse la firme possède
déjà trois personnages dans smash bros
il se peut que sakurai préférerait
privilégier d'autres compagnies pour
apporter plus de diversité dans le
casting est d'ailleurs au vu du
fanatisme que montre sakurai pour street
fighter il se pourrait qu'il préférerait
ramener à nouveau un personnage de cette
licence
mais cela reste à voir enfin s'il y en a
bien un qui al sommes aujourd'hui c'est
waluigi le dernier personnage de la
série mario qui mériterait d'avoir sa
place dans le jeu même la plante piranha
l'a humilié mais justement je me dis
aujourd'hui
sakura est un gros troll il est très
proche des fans et est très actif sur
twitter il c'est l'engouement de ces
derniers par rapport à waluigi essayez
d'imaginer un seul instant que le
dernier dlc le tout dernier personnage à
rejoindre
ultimate soit waluigi le même aurait
pris vie et la foule serait en délire
ils ont bien intégré sens donc pour moi
tout reste encore possible
merci à tous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
ça me fait vraiment plaisir
essayez quand même de garder en tête que
tout ce qu'on vient de dire c'est quand
même des avis subjectif et que ce ne
sont que des théories après tout je vous
invite très fortement à les voir la
chaîne de mes deux confrères ue et nm lt
le studio poker août
bon ils ne sortent pas vraiment beaucoup
de vidéos mais à chaque sortie c'est
vraiment un phénomène
je vous encourage vraiment aller voir
merci de tout coeur à ceux qui
laisseront un pouce bleu un commentaire
et qui s'abonneront à la chaîne on se
retrouve très prochainement pour
d'autres vidéos théorie et puis écouté
que le liner ce soit avec vous allez
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]